hey there i'm dan frawls and this is
things to know before you go to The
Hunger Games Mockingjay part 2 it's sure
to be an emotional conclusion to the
Hunger Games saga so be sure to bring
the tissues oh my god that is not how we
rehearsed it
so after surviving two Hunger Games and
rescuing a brainwashed Peeta from the
Capitol Katniss and the rebels have
readied themselves to take down Santa
Claus I mean President Snow I could go
into further detail but chances are if
you're watching this video you've
already seen the Hunger Games movies or
you just think I'm hot so what can we
expect from part two more action some
criticized Mockingjay part 1 for being
light on the fight scenes but have no
fear because part two packs a punch
director Francis Lawrence has said he
considers this the most violent of the
Hunger Games films and the final battle
scenes are so epic they've been working
on the visual effects for them since
before the first Mockingjay was released
along with more action it's a safe bet
we'll see more emotion early buzz on
this film is that it's a tense emotional
thrill ride so as I said bring those
tissues good oh my god we did not
rehearse it like that Liam Hemsworth aka
Gayle said that from start to finish it
doesn't give up and that the whole time
you feel like anyone could be killed at
any moment it sounds like we'll also be
getting a conclusion The Hunger Games
book trilogy written by Suzanne Collins
ended it Mockingjay and that's most
likely where the movie series will end
as well but that hasn't stopped
Lionsgate from exploring new options for
the franchise could there be another
sequel or a prequel or an epic battle
between lines gates biggest franchises
but if this truly is the end of The
Hunger Games series you can still look
forward to the Hunger Games attractions
at lions gates upcoming a patron theme
park in Atlanta hey kids who wants to go
in The Hunger Games ride only one of you
will survive but forget all that there's
still one awesome Hunger Games movie to
enjoy will Katniss and the rebels emerge
victorious against the Capitol or will
President Snow have the last laugh head
to theaters November 20th to find out or
just read the books what we don't make
my Netflix hit the theaters to find out
you
you